[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est qu'internet internet
or je sais pas d'informatique de
communication c'est les nouveaux
autoroutes de l'information
voilà il est intelligent mon copain et
du greta terrine
la publicité ça c'est un programme tout
permettre savoir
ça vend un peu tout internet c'est le
nettoyage internet
je pense que ça veut dire pierre cau
c'est comme un énorme minitel on peut
avoir une femme à son immense avec tous
les pays
internet j'ai cru comprendre que ça
rapport avec l'informatique la
désinformation qui circule et qui sont
accessibles à tout le monde sait ça et
qu'il faut un ordinateur pour cela non
j'ai pas lu j'ai pas le temps j'ai
rendez-vous internet soit je sais pas
vous allez chez le coiffeur
oui vous la sentez à refaire mais non
[Musique]